hello everyone and welcome to game eight
or rather game four of the second match
between anish giri and yani pony shigeru
was able to win
uh uh one game after five draws geary
won the sixth game and now nipple needs
to bounce back the seventh game ended in
a draw rather the third game of the
second match and now this is the final
game so either nipple wins
and takes everything into tie breaks or
giri only needs a draw
and um well he wins the entire thing and
it's like the dream scenario uh the gear
needs a draw to win the entire event uh
let's see what happens here
and for those of you who are interested
in joining our telegram group
uh it was banned for some reason some
users did some funky stuff over there
but
i was able to unban it and now everyone
can join if you're interested still in
that it's
the first link in the description below
there we discussed you know a lot of
stuff
just of course being the main topic so
uh that being said let's check out the
game geary only needing a draw
opens with e4 and once again we see c5
and interestingly in all
in all eight games so far uh both
players went for the sicilian defense uh
we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and now for the final game
geary goes for bishop to b5 the
medina rossolimo attack we have e6
preparing to strike in the center with
d5 and now
uh bishop captures we have b captures
and d3
so this has all been played before
nothing out of the ordinary
knights to e7 uh and here knight b to d2
by giri uh
giri already has one game in the
database that was played in 2019 against
magnus cross and in croatia and zagreb
where he played h4
uh and the gear lost that game to magnus
but here gary goes knight b to d2
obviously did some improvement on the
line
knight to g6 by on and now h4 preparing
to kick away the knight with h5 uh
so jan of course plays h5 himself and
now e5
are kind of paralyzing the position but
jan of course just
strikes in the center with d6 f6 is a
known move here kind of undermining the
central pawn with a with a not so
central pawn but here d6 is a new move
so already as of move eight we have a
completely new game
so here uh geary decides to trade we
have captures uh but now not captures a
rather e5 this was jan's idea uh when
playing d6 obviously some sort of a
deep preparation when he needs uh an
absolute win
at knight to c4 defending and attacking
an e5
and bishop to g4 now pinning one of the
attackers of the e5 pawn we have bishop
to g5
attacking nipples queen and here only
now nepal goes for f6 kicks back the
bishop
uh so bishop back to d2 and now finally
he picks up the pawn
bishop captures on d6 and now queen to
e2 so preparing the castle queen side
uh bishop back to c7 by nepal not
allowing this trade and
also the bishop might be very useful
later on uh and now
queenside castles uh we have king side
castles by nipple and now king to b1
an ice prophylactic move by giri uh and
rook to b8 the rook is now perfectly
aligned for
um for attacking and rook d to g1
now by giri uh we have knight to f for
bayan
uh going after the queen here and giri
decides to give back the bishop uh to
eliminate this very strong attacker so
captures captures this also kind of
ruins the unspawn structure
uh and you can see that ian has three
pawn islands with his c
pawns and f1 being doubled but he
doesn't care he needs a win
and there's a saying inches whenever you
need a win create an imbalance in the
position whether it's giving your
opponent a little bit of positional
advantage you need to create imbalances
to gain some sort of an advantage
so here after he captures an f4 rook
back to e1
now grabbing control of the e file and
the queen to d5 now
the bishop can be shifted over to e6 if
needed at some point
maybe put some pressure here on on the
queen side but also uh you want to
connect your rooks and
centralize the queen and the queen is
very much centralized on d5
so here queen back to d1 uh and now
comes rook f2 e8 nipple counters the
gears rooks on the e file
b3 uh and now king to f7 now nepo slowly
but surely brings his king into the game
we have a for bhagiri
and now rook beat d8 so what do you play
here gary starts with king to a2
interestingly
uh it's nipples position uh that has
ruined pawn structure but it's geary
that's basically without an active move
you don't really have anything good with
the rooks you don't have
all that much the knight here is pinned
very hard to unpin this if you move the
queen just captures and captures wins
material
and the situation on the clock is gear
is down to 10 minutes whereas nepo has
some very solid 13 minutes and here
the problem is uh okay nipple goes for
king to g6 you could go for bishop
captures on f3 right away for example
and then if
queen captures you just trade everything
off rook captures rook captures
queen captures and then you ruin white's
pawn structure and then you strike in
the center with g5 so this is possible
let's say rook g1 rogue g8 and now we
can see a trade here captures captures
and we get this position black gets the
king into the game
and already has a very nice past h pawn
but uh nepo says nope
it's not the time for that gear is the
one without moves let's not force
anything
uh let's just keep it solid so he goes
king to g6 uh
brings the king closer uh to where the
action is
uh and now uh we have rook h the g1
uh now uh the the g2 pawn will be
defended if the position opens up and
also
you might be able to move the queen now
if bishop captures if captures this will
come with
check so nipple quickly gets the king
out of the way king to h6
also makes room for the g5 pawn and now
rook back to h1 by giri we have queen
back to f7
and now kink to b1 giri is basically
without a move and waiting to see what
happens
so uh bishop back to e6 and now knight
after d2 the knight might be able to
come to e4 but now bishop to d5 puts
pressure on the g2 pawn
and geary needs to make a very ugly
decision whether to push
f3 or not the problem with f3 is that
okay you might have a nice outpost for
your knight on e4 but nipple would
immediately
play f5 and there's no knight to e4 and
your pieces are not going anywhere
and even if you try to do something
along the e file for example rook to e1
and nipple just goes rook e7 and you
either capture and then nipple controls
the entire e file or you play something
doesn't really matter what and then
nipple forces you to capture because now
rook captures rook is the threat
so captures captures and here we would
get this position where nepal
would be uh the only one controlling the
e file and he would still have the
bishop
pair g5 is coming at some point it's a
it's a very nice position for black
so instead rook h back to g1 by geary
and now comes queen to g6 uh
just getting the queen a little bit
closer to the action
uh we have rook capture 78 again gary
without uh without an active move he
decides to do something
rook captures rook captures and now f3
uh now if he can get this knight to e4
all would be well but
nepo of course will not allow that he
pushes f5 and now queen to
f1 so giri has to play something and now
queen to g3 going after the h4 pawn
so rook to h1 defending and now bishop
to d8 here nipple made a very
interesting decision he actually allows
this knight to come to d6 rook to e6
it's kind of the same idea the nipple
play the guards this square prepares
this goes after this pawn
and it kind of limits white's counter
play but nipple says nope
there's no need for that nipple goes
bishop to d8 right away and he actually
allows
knight to d6 and the gear immediately
jumps uh with
the knight knight to d6 attacks the rook
and now you can no longer play rook to
e6
because this knight captures an f5 uh
with a nice royal fork you lose the
queen and the game
so instead after knight to d6 we have
rook to f8 now
uh guarding guarding that f5 pawn uh and
now comes knight uh knight um
uh comes to c4 uh you could try to get
the queen to the e file now but there's
really no
uh use for the queen there and none of
the squares are available to you the
bishops are covering all of the squares
the rook covers the eights so the
queen's pretty much useless there you
just
waste the h4 pawn and that's it if c4
you can even go for rook to f6 you go
after the knight let's say captures
captures
and if captures captures i mean black is
still with a with a very nice position
but white could maybe play something
like queen to e8 go after the rook maybe
threaten some queen to h8 maybe knight
c4 to e5
who knows but that's the beauty of rapid
chess we never know
so instead after rook to f8 the gear we
went for knight c to e4 immediately
and now bishop captures on h4 so
grabbing that pawn
and now again if you go queen e2 uh for
example just g6 all of the squares are
still taken the queen is very much
useless here on the e file so instead
after bishop to h4 we have knight to e5
by geary those knights are looking very
scary now
but nepal says it doesn't matter just
rook to f6 attacks the knight here and
here gary really started to burn his
clock uh he went all the way down to
below a minute where his nipple has over
seven minutes on the clock
and it's uh well the rook is on the
knight is under attack you could play
something like knight b7
but it's still very ugly yes you are
attacking the c5 pawn but queen f2
you're defending it
not much for white to hope for if
captures captures the bishop still
defends it
black retains a better position so
instead giri had to try something he
played c4 but this is a bit over
committal
and also weakens the the king's position
very much
so here nepo uh played a very nice
bishop
back to g8 you could also go for this
trade but nepo says nope you're the one
that's slow on time i'm not gonna force
anything
just waste your time so here aguirre
finally goes knight to b7
uh but now rook to e6 attacks this
knight
and also what are you going to play here
so here uh
geary went for the very quick queen to
h3 but now
the position is completely lost for for
geary and nipple has a brilliant
brilliant move that
wins the game on the spot so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
this
idea while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always
sacrificing your queen in the right
moment and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
rook captures on e5 that's the good
stuff and here you can basically resign
but uh giri decided to capture the queen
there's nothing to be done here rook d1
is coming
uh giri captured the queen but after
bishop captures on g3 it was in this
position on move 38
that uh anishigiri resigned the game
and nepo wins the first game of the
finals which means that
the score is now a tie and he forces
tiebreak so really really incredible
stuff
uh and we will have more games between
these two gentlemen so here you resign
because
rook to e1 wins back the queen and
there's nothing you can do uh if you
move the queen
where are you going to move the queen to
rook to e1 is still coming and
the beauty of uh king to c2 is that now
well you might have rooked king to b2 if
this pawn
uh remained here on c2 but now even if
you move the king
just rookie one and the queen is still
trapped even without check there's no
square for the queen you have to capture
it
and then after captures captures you're
just up a piece with a completely
winning endgame there it's
really a no-brainer you just push some
pawns and win the game
so yeah after bishop captures on g3 uh
an amazing
victory for yani ponishi who wins the a
must win
in the final game of the finals with a
beautiful queen sacrifice on e5
uh with rook captures and e5 just just
amazing stuff
so yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it gary certainly didn't he was
again this close to winning but again
in that final moment he he finds a way
to give his opponent a chance
uh so what are you gonna do uh i would
like to thank enrique villarreal
uh jeff langley and goddess rustica
michael carlin and christian vissers for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the finals checking up on
your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest
rest of your day and do join our
telegram group the first link in the
description below
see you soon